now's the perfect time of year to
explore a tropical climate
but yara might not be the most welcoming
but we have a pair of guides on hand
david kavari
and benjamin hall here to help us
explore the island how are you both
good good i'm still beaming that you're
saying my last name right
it's fantastic so one of the main things
that i'm getting a lot from seeing far
cry 6
is that you over there are making a game
of contrasts one of the first things
that strikes out is
you came out pretty recently and said
this is a political game that's pretty
contrasting to a lot of games as we know
you sort of
avoid that and you've come out in the
open said no this is a political game
but what i want to know
is what came first did you did you start
thinking we want to make a political
game or did you
build the setting and think this is
actually the perfect time for us to say
something now
the reality is any work you put out is
is gonna be inherently political i think
it's just to what
degree is it political so for me
it was uh and the team it was more
looking at
you know revolution you know what are
the themes that emerge from revolution
as a as a writer as a narrative director
as a as a project you're gonna
uh soak up you know the themes that are
present
every day around you right so i think
for us when we were looking at okay
we're looking at
making a story about a modern day
revolution what are the questions that
are going to be asked
you know in this fictional context from
our characters so
we wanted to go to places of talking
about
imperialism we wanted to talk about what
are the conditions of the rise
of fascism you know that you're never
safe
from tyranny that uh you know human
rights abuses free and fair elections
like these are
these are questions that that i think
are
present now uh just as they were uh
50 years ago 100 years ago 150 years ago
so
i think what what i was trying to do
uh with the statement and by talking to
the team
right from the beginning is just to say
let's not
be let's be fearless about how we
approach this
and and and focus on the story we're
telling because the best fiction
i think has um has some meaning to it
you know it asks questions and we really
wanted to do that with
with far cry 6 balancing that with
you know an epic a game you know an epic
revolutionary
game that's that's what we were aiming
for yeah and then from
the world side that meant that we could
look at it really looking at the
different layers of history
so taking into account all of those
different elements and i've just talked
about
the 50-year mark the 100-year mark we
really wanted to tie into that and when
we were crafting the world with the team
we wanted to show that those layers of
history
within the world of yara as well like we
said before you've been talking about
this being a game of contrasts
but far cry has always been a series
that's
worn almost slapstick nature action
moving nature
quite freely has that been at odds with
like
telling a serious message while also
having a game including
a alligator with a t-shirt on does that
sort of
muddy the water a bit or do you find it
that players might find it even more
accessible to take in this message
if there's sort of a familiar action
movie-esque
wrapper around it you can't really have
one without the other
when you're doing a far cry game and
it's all about
balance i think in its dna you know
in the brand it's about having mature
themes it's about
having powerful you know villains that
that will charm you and try and convince
you of their
their opinion but marry that with
you know some humor some action
adventure you know and i think to what i
was speaking about
earlier i think the best sort of fiction
the best action adventure
you know stories and games you know
it's all wrapped into one package one
unified
package and i think you know my job and
the team's job is just
making sure we find that balance and so
right now we've been talking a lot more
about the game play but as more of the
content comes out and you know once
you're able to get a hands-on
you'll see that we really tried to
ground
uh these elements these sort of wilder
elements uh
in the fiction you know so you've seen
the
the what we call the resolver weapons
from juan cortez you know juan cortez is
this
spymaster who you know would wait
doing ambushes in the jungle and he's
had to do this diy
philosophy and he got inspired by
reading comic books and he was like you
know what i'm
we can do some you know really crazy
things if we get
creative with our with our weaponry so
it was just about grounding that into
the world and i think you're going to
see
a lot more of that to come there seems
to be from from what we've seen so far
there seems to be more
contrast in the play styles too with the
a lot of customization
exclamation building your vehicles and
and your weapons
to me as someone who favors like the
sort of stealthy approach in far cry
games
it looks like there is this contrast has
almost played
into allowing more diverse
diversification in the way that you're
actually
able to play far cry is that is that
sort of something that naturally
happened or was that one of your goals
i was definitely one of the goals that
we wanted to set out with was giving the
player
as much agency as possible when it comes
to how they want to approach different
scenarios and
and different elements of the the story
the missions but also when they're out
in the open world hitting the
checkpoints or the the flat cannons
so tie in the resolver philosophy into
the gear sets and the the weaponry meant
that we could really
allow players to build themselves out in
in different play styles so
being a stealth player is great because
it means that you're going to be able to
make sure you're going to find different
pieces of equipment and
change your weapon loadout and different
resolver weapons as well there's
different ones that kind of
promote being able to play in a more
stealthy way so you'll be able to gear
yourself up in that way and approach
different scenarios in a in a way where
you you know you're going to go in and
try and play quietly
you know comparing that to someone else
like i like to go in loud so i'm going
to equip myself with all the gear with
the i'm going to have to
yeah i'm getting strike i'm going to go
in with the flamethrower and
it's going to be a different experience
than the one that you have and that was
something that was important to us from
the beginning
yeah the team sometimes i think my team
anyway sometimes hates playing with me
because
i will destroy everything the moment i
the moment i head up into an fnd base
and it's like the perfectly laid out
narrative and conversations
um but yeah it's definitely part of the
experience what i want to know is the
story behind the meeting where you
decided on macarena would be the song of
choice to attack people in
i can't imagine that's a stealth weapon
either that's that's that's on the
louder spectrum
i think i think all the weapons really
the resolver weapons like like now
touched on earlier the fact that you
know we've we've taken this fantasy this
resolver philosophy and then fused it
with the idea that one had
combining it with these these kind of
comics comic book stories that it
had been reading really allowed the team
to just kind of go wild so like the
concept art team had so much fun doing
different drawings different styles
different ideas of
taking all these pieces of everyday
items and and jamming them together
and and all of that has just allowed the
team really to have so much freedom and
expression with the
the different the levels of ingenuity in
in the gear sets when it comes to the
resolver equipment
the the macarena i think it was was it
with eduardo or audio director
yeah we were it must have been our audio
director eduardo
i'll throw him under the bus
but yeah i i honestly i didn't see the
reaction coming people
love people love that gun so it's great
is that going to be the only song then
or if you're going to have like the
greatest hits to
attack palu military to
i don't want to stand for eduardo yet
yeah i think i think we'll save that
we'll save that for
more to come on that one
i'll speak to the soundtrack of the game
like i don't want to uh
spoil any anything that's common but
just the soundtracks phenomenal the work
that's been done by edward on his team
and then
and then obviously working with pedro
bronfman on the actual you know
the composed composition of the music is
phenomenal
and and working with those guys in terms
of how we
we've worked with the music with the
different scenarios that we put you into
but also the different areas of the
world that you're exploring
the music changes and evolves as you
travel through the
the environment and and it's i'm looking
forward to people
people playing that for sure and i think
that just to follow up on that the
the balance that that they found on the
audio side
of you know licensed music finding
artists like really unique and diverse
artists
that can speak to you know latin
american what you'd hear
on the radio you know in the caribbean
it's so much so much fun they put a ton
of work
into finding um amazing tracks that you
can listen to while you're driving in
your
vintage car and then on the you know
balance that with
pedro bronfman's score which uh
i think a lot of folks are responding to
right now in a lot of ways pedro's score
i call it like the the other character
in the game it's like almost like a
narrator
over the entire game that just sort of
sucks you in and
it just helps push the story push the
meaning even further so
i you know i got that score playing
constantly
while we're writing so uh yeah i'm
excited for people to see more
the world you're building is also quite
a
new direction for you as well isn't it
you've visited the tropical locales
before but this is the first time
we're seeing a much more built urban
environment with
with armor and streets and much taller
buildings
has that been a challenge for you to
create or has that been like sort of
an exciting new locale to start building
it's certainly been an exciting
challenge for the team i mean when we
set up with this idea of building a
modern day guerrilla revolution and the
idea of
of having this dictator that was
controlling the country those words kept
coming up like the idea of a country and
an actual place that you're going to
fight for that's an entire country so
that was really
what kind of brought that to life the
idea that the team we wanted to build
the notion of it being an entire place
so
looking at it from an infrastructure
point of view and the historical point
of view likely to create this place that
feels like it's been there for a very
long time and as the player goes through
it they get to learn about the history
and and the different challenges that
the islands had throughout throughout
its time period but then also that yeah
bringing in those urban environments was
something that that really
helps make it feel like it's a place
where people lived people worked and
people still do
and and now just under different to you
know different terms so this this idea
that the the island been frozen in time
you get to see these decaying
urban areas that are punctuated through
the landscapes of these beautiful
biomes that you get to explore that in
themselves
are so diverse going to the the
caribbean and building a caribbean
island really allowed us to just tap
into so many different types of
floor and fauna and landscape i was it
was great for the team the team really
enjoyed getting into that and
utilizing that to build our yara and
having such like a dense and expansive
island as well how have you had to sort
of balance that
with ensuring the experience is
the same or as close to as possible over
both generations are there going to be
differences will will be less dense on
on older consoles have you had to sort
of
make amends somewhat to make sure things
are running on both generations how is
that how does that work for you
no the team have been working incredibly
hard to to get the the game running
uh smoothly for everybody so that's
really been the the goal that we've had
is to is to make this experience
smooth for everyone no matter what
console that you're on and then
obviously playing on
the newer machines that i've got more
power that there's different things that
we can do with it in terms of
shadows and draw distances and and being
4k
60 fps on on next gen consoles obviously
the the loading speed
uh getting into the content as well
makes a difference but really
the team's focus and goal has been
making sure that we can create an
experience that's
as smooth as possible uh for everyone on
on
those gen 4 consoles too and i want to
talk a little bit about
the sort of crafting and customization
um with some of the weapons the vehicles
is it almost an homage to a real latin
america where the idea of
of building new things that ingenuity
plays a lot into the way of life
especially
in places like cuba is that sort of your
nod to the the industrious people making
stuff
and and living their life through that
sort of medium yeah i think the
inspiration
really was uh seeing how how
you know how people can under you know
difficult circumstances under
you know a blockade can find ingenious
ways
uh to to to survive and make do
you know with with what they have uh
around them and i think
uh for us it was about honoring that but
also you know
you know pushing that to you know how
does that apply
you know in a modern revolution and when
you look at you know revolutions in
history
um it's always about this small group
using the whatever tools they can
scrounge up whatever tools they can get
their hands on
uh to fight this overwhelming
force and so um it felt this sort of diy
aesthetic felt very uh natural
in the context of far cry 6 and i think
the creativity the ingenuity the
surprise
that you'll find in our weaponry and our
customization in the looks
that you put on as a character i think
is is going to be really exciting and i
think it's it's another way
for players to express themselves right
within the universe of
far cry 6. so i'm really excited to see
how people respond to that
and finally just a quick one i know you
can't give too much away but
as someone who was a big fan of far cry
5 the ending of that was hugely
impactful
and i know you've briefly touched on it
in some interviews in the past
but is that sort of high impact not only
to the individual story of you're
telling but to the
the wider narrative of far cry are you
sort of swinging for the fences for that
big unexpected ending again or are you
are you keeping all right you know i
can't talk about that
i don't use the word
what was most important when we were
working on the narrative was
that you would have uh you know
a satisfy a feeling of satisfaction you
know
of the revolution and of your experience
in the revolution
and it really come boils down to the
themes of the game
and the characters and the journey of
danny themselves
so uh you know it's an epic story
so it will have a an epic
conclusion and you'll just have to wait
and see
well gentlemen thank you so much for
this brief tour around yara i can't wait
to visit the island myself
october 7th and everyone out there make
sure to subscribe to gamespot because
we're going to have
tons more far cry 6 content coming your
way over the next weeks months
gentlemen thank you so much thank you
[Music]
you